yes sister this question concerns those who
work in the medical field yes the nurses doctors
um what happened to our institution our hospitals
and so forth so they pay because they have to
work on sabbath yeah they pay they pay in many
things we do sister we're just like the world in
many now this is my church i'll die for it you
can't get me out of this church except in a coffin
but i also know there are many things we do that
are simply influenced by the world whether it's
our hospitals our schools our publishing houses i
just sometimes you shake your head and you realize
the israelites were no different they were god's
people but crazy and we are very much that way
but don't give up this is god's church it is
the object still of his supreme regard i was
an adventist bookstore once and i have books by td
jake and this but i said what was the problem here
and you know this come on are we here to make a
difference or not you go to hospitals you see a
vending machine with coke and sprite and you know
we have a health message but we're still god's
people and god has to spank us sometimes to get
us straight so don't be discouraged sister we're
still god's people pray do what you can god will
fix this church when he does it will be painful
i need a pastor's permission yes
you